non vi parlerò di innovazione
tecnologica o almeno come come me la sto
immaginando il prima di raccontarvi un
po quello che sto facendo
vi voglio raccontare una storia che vi
fa capire anche che il tema della
sostenibilità è un tema che viene da
lontano e il primo questo racconto che
vi voglio narrare riguarda una storia
meravigliosa marco polo attraversa da
venezia fino alla cina e quando arriva
in persia nel cuore della pes e quindi
siamo tradirà khedira luogo di deserti
un caldo micidiale quando arriva in un
villaggio i persiani il segno di
benvenuto
siamo nel 1472 73 il segno di benvenuto
e gli offrono un gelato al tamarindo del
270 nel 470 con gelato al tamarindo è
una domanda a cui bisogna dare una
risposta no pensi come facevano a
mangiare il gelato ma allora è per
questo che poi importante con
l'architettura di persiani probabilmente
ci hanno messo secoli a capire come
funzionava il meccanismo quindi siamo in
un periodo
l'energia non c'è poi costruivano questo
edificio che voi vedete che un grande
muro esposto a sud
questo muro proteggeva una piccola
chiamiamo la piscina un piccolo
avvallamento e davanti a questo modo c'è
una grande cupola che era stato ottenuto
scavando una cisterna che i persiani
cosa facevano di note depositavano uno
strato sottile d'acqua di questa
questa piscina e siccome il muro ha
protetto tutto il giorno dalle sole
quell'area non aveva avuto nessun
guadagno termico non c'è ma non si è mai
scaldato per effetto della calotta
celeste e come voi sapete quando
viaggiate in aereo che il comandante
dice la temperatura esterna meno 55
gradi la carota celeste e meno 55 gradi
e per effetto della radiazione celeste
in un periodo storico dove non c'era
ovviamente inquinamento la trasparenza
del cielo per effetto della variazione
celeste questo strato di acqua
ghiacciata e notte dopo notte i persiani
toglievano rompevano questo ghiaccio che
lo metteva di questa cisterna durante
l'estate 55 gradi più esterni una cupola
protegge questa questo grande invaso di
ghiaccio attraverso un semplice
principio di ventilazione quindi alla
radiazione del sole che si trasformava
in una temperatura all'interno di questo
di questa cupola veniva poi espulso
attraverso attraverso un sistema di
ventilazione naturale
questo è una delle architetture poche
purtroppo rimaste dovute alla guerra che
potrà essere un fatto negativo e anche
una distruzione della cultura allora
questo esempio è un esempio importante
perché i persiani nonostante il grande
calore estivo si mangiava un gelato
durante l'estate lo offrivano e da noi
forse a roma avrebbero chiamato una
grattachecca diciamo che è uno e chi e
ghiaccio triturato insieme insieme alle
all'essenza questo è un esempio che per
me è importante raccontarvi perché
stiamo guardando quello che succederà
nei prossimi 30 40 50 anni
ora per darmi una dimensione del
problema e poi mi e poi capirete perché
vi ho parlato di marco polo
perché parlare di sostenibilità è
importante perché quello che sta
succedendo non ha precedenti nella
nostra storia cioè tanto per darvi dei
numeri sulla terra sono stati costruiti
a oggi 145 miliardi di metri quadri che
non so neanche io dirvi quanto sono
fisicamente tanta roba
tanta roba allora però il punto non è
quello il punto che nei prossimi 15 anni
costruiremo la metà di quello che
abbiamo da sempre costruito questa è la
dimensione del problema ma ho 73
miliardi di metri quadri sono più o meno
un miliardo di alloggi c'è questo è
quello che succederà e che sta piano
piano succedendo nei paesi che stanno
crescendo magari l'italia un problema
diverso però in altri paesi del mondo
per poter fare quello cioè per costruire
75 73 miliardi di metri quadrati abbiamo
bisogno di cemento di vetro di mattoni
di calcio abbiamo bisogno di portare
l'acqua in qualche posto abbiamo bisogno
di fare del raffrescamento come queste
immagini che vi fanno capire anche la
dimensione del consumo no allora non è
che ci siamo affidati un po troppo alla
tecnologia perché poi la tecnologia e in
questo caso io parlo con l'edilizia non
parla della tecnologia in senso più
vasto
la tecnologia negli edifici è stata una
grande conquista perché negli ultimi 50
anni abbiamo vissuto in edifici che non
avevamo più nessun rapporto con il clima
non era totalmente indifferente sapere
se fuori c'era caldo c'era freddo io
avevo il mio condizionatore sul mio
controllo termico ecco questa questa
innovazione tecnologica che è stato un
po come uso è un po come questi robot
non sono un po un sogno dell'uomo non
fare qualcosa contro
ora però adesso quella natura ci ha
presentato un conto ma se avete voluto
gli edifici tecnologici meno adesso
abbiamo una sede i problemi che abbiamo
sentito anche prima che sono poi quelli
del cambiamento del clima condizioni di
cambiamento locale
allora forse nel guardare anche gli
obiettivi dei prossimi anni
noi ci dobbiamo porre delle questioni
ora per darmi un altro dato semplice
ogni settimana si spostano dalle
campagne nelle città un milione e mezzo
di persone questo è da transumanza che
sta avvenendo anche su questo varrebbe
la pena di discutere perché questo
grande fenomeno della delle megalopoli è
stato un grande sogno è anche una grande
opportunità però ha avuto anche alcune
piccoli effetti collaterali no per
quello che servito occasione di vederla
b snav e parliamo proprio delle aree
interne cioè quelle aree che non sono
città metropolitane perché sono dei
giacimenti culturali
allora che cosa sta succedendo noi
abbiamo davanti una road map che è stata
l'europa ha disegnato uno scenario è
questo scenario non ha più alternative
la strada è questa non è dal 1992 che
oriali già nero che c'è a ogni anno da
21 anni
una conferenza sul cambiamento del clima
l'ultimo accordo cosa di parigi e quello
che diciamo quello più di successo è
anche il risultato di 20 anni
discussioni ma perché è importante il
tempo no perché qui il tema vero non è
solo il cambiamento del clima che quello
tanto arriverà comunque che vogliamo non
vogliamo tutti gli sforzi che faremo il
vero cambiamento qui al cambiamento
culturale cioè noi dobbiamo entrare in
un'altra era cioè non siamo più dentro
l'era diciamo del dell'uso dei
combustibili fosse insieme in un'altra
era un air ecologica di unire ecologica
come qui vedete questo che sta questa
mappa si dice che nel 2020 nel 2030
avremo degli appuntamenti ma l'obiettivo
qual è l'obiettivo è ridurre le
emissioni di gas serra non è ancora
nonostante l'accordo di parigi
quest'anno gli indici di crescita e non
di decreto
ma allora il framework che cosa ci dice
io ve ne parlo sembra che non sto
parlando di architettura fortuna
importante perché il mondo costruito
contribuisce per il 70 per cento alle
emissioni di co2 di consumi energetici
quindi abbiamo assolutamente titolo per
parlar meno ora qui ci chiedono di
ridurre le emissioni di co2 adesso a
parte i numeri di fare delle storie
energetico e dall'altra parte di
consumare meno energia ma com'è che
facciamo a fare questo perché tutti co2
non si vede in una società di immagine
una cosa che non si vede non esiste come
facciamo a produrre energia rinnovabile
come facciamo a consumarne di meno
allora forse ed è questo che mi sembra
che il tema più interessante forse
dobbiamo andare a pescare proprio in
quell enorme giacimento culturale che la
nostra storia in cui si sono costruiti
edifici dove l'energia non c'era come
hanno fatto per duemila anni a fare
edifici meravigliosi dove l'energia non
era una delle componenti essenziali
allora questo mi fa pensare che il tema
dell'innovazione ma un po forse forse
dovremmo può rivedere no che cosa
l'innovazione è soltanto una macchina se
soltanto un programma se soltanto un
computer o forse nell'edilizia
nell'architettura
dobbiamo ritrovare una relazione io
chiamo di empatia con l'ambiente quindi
ci sono degli esempi meravigliosa io vi
voglio tediare con tante cose però per
secoli gli uomini si sono hanno creato
un ambiente o cui di una complicità con
l'ambiente non ho costruito questo sono
direttori del vento quando prendono
evento predominante lo portano dentro le
case era fresca nelle case di notte e di
giorno ci sono dieci gradi di meno ora è
chiaro che noi non vogliamo fare questo
questo è il passato io non sono un
nostalgico né tantomeno o quella
quell'idea che il passato è sempre
meglio del futuro io credo che il futuro
sarà sempre meglio no però mi
incuriosisce no mi incuriosiscono per
esempio i pachistani
che fanno queste torri con questa specie
di caccia questa aquilone che raccoglie
il vento incarnava nelle case e riduce
la domanda di temperatura di notte
queste case sono più fresche e di giorno
fuori ci sono 50 gradi dentro ce ne sono
42 ci sono 7 8 gradi di differenza
allora tutto questo mi fa pensare che lì
dentro in questi questi edifici non li
rifaremo sicuramente così però si
nasconde una conoscenza cioè sapevano
come si faceva si sapeva come reagirà
allora se l'europa mi sta dicendo
e noi tutti stiamo lavorando con questa
idea che gli edifici del 2020 cioè
dopodomani devono essere a quasi energia
zero e quel quasi dovrebbe essere fatta
con una fonte rinnovabile
la prima cosa che mi viene in mente viva
da studiare i pakistani se mi vado a
studiare quelli che con l'energia hanno
avuto questa complicità poi noi viviamo
in un mondo dove abbiamo un'opportunità
che non abbiamo mai avuto è quella
appunto della tecnologia loro non
avevano neanche un computer ma i
persiani forse facendo tante prove
avevano capito che è un certo movimento
questo rapporto con l'ambiente poteva
essere molto vantaggioso cioè
quell'energia che era fuori era qualcosa
che poteva essere utile all'uomo che non
era contro l'uomo era per lui noi questa
cosa l'abbiamo totalmente persa se
abbiamo completamente perso la capacità
di dialogare con l'ambiente perché
abbiamo avuto un sogno meraviglioso
abbiamo detto ma da scuola tecnologia
con le macchine facciamo tutto quello
che ci parla figurati quello che c'è
fuori non ci interessa ecco questa cosa
qui non funziona più allora mi piace
pensare che il futuro dell'innovazione
sia di fatto una cosa ibridano forse c'è
tecnologia ma c'è anche conoscenza c'è
anche qualcosa che noi sapevamo fare noi
lo sapevamo fare questa cosa ma allora
un altro esempio meraviglioso
questa è proprio una storia da
architetti questo è un palazzo amenábar
da scavare invece che costruito sopra la
terra è scavato sotto terra ogni dieci
metri che si scende si perde un grado e
questa erano le carte
e le piazze dove si rifugiavano gli
indiani quando forti c'erano 60 gradi ed
erano anche dei luoghi pubblici quindi
erano l'edificio al contrario nella
penombra la terra come voi sapete quando
voi scavate la terra dopo alcuni metri
la temperatura costante intorno ai 16 17
gradi se io per quello c'è un
architettura ipogea straordinaria quando
io vado sotto terra
qualunque sia la temperatura esterna
io dentro sto a 18 20 gradi ora la cosa
bella di questo edificio se vi capita si
chiama step well in india era avvenuto
talmente bene questo edificio il
maharaja era così contento che ha ucciso
i sei architetti che erano state e fuori
dall'ingresso di questo edificio ci sono
in forma d onore
l'effetto ombre di gres non vedere è
talmente bello che non lo dovete più
fare per nessuno ecco questi sono i
rischi del mestiere e io oggi meno pane
e qui torniamo anche su il fatto della
responsabilità perché fare questo
mestiere io dico sempre gli architetti
sono delle persone molto pericolose
perché possono far costruire delle cose
meravigliose possono lasciare degli
incubi e di tubi ce ne sono tanti in
giro per il mondo
questa è la grande e la camera dello
scirocco dove i catanesi si rifugiavano
quando c'era lo scirocco e questa camera
non una ventilazione naturale permetteva
di stare sotto ora vi faccio vedere due
cose semplici per chiudere che cosa
anche il rapporto con la natura ma
queste sono le dune d'algeri e queste
sono queste costruzioni di pietra che si
facevano per raccogliere la temperatura
e acari cambia giorno notte e umidità
intorno a queste pietre si condensava
l'acqua dell'umidita e se con se
arrivano delle bozze per poter dar da
bere agli animali la forma è stato poi
l'oggetto di questo questo è un edificio
che stiamo facendo ad algeri è che il
primo edificio che affronta questo tema
della sostenibilità dei consumi in un
paese che il più grande produttore di
gas del mondo questa è una palma è una e
una una grotta di sale
la cui è nato questo edificio che in
ghana che abbiamo fatto
per un developer il ghanese e che è
diventato un landmark perché è
ricollegato alcuni temi che avranno
perduti non l'ombreggiatura ventilazione
naturale tutti i temi che hanno permesso
a questo edificio di funzionare per la
metà dell'anno senza nessun
condizionamento soltanto attraverso un
principio passivo quindi mi piace
pensare che fosse il futuro dei nostri
edifici non è più hi tech
la cosa quell'edificio muscolare piena
di impianti ma forse una mediazione tra
conoscenza e innovazione e chiudo con
questa immagine un saluto questo è un
beduino con il suo cammello che
attraversa il deserto
vabbè detto questo però se io cambio al
punto di vista e vi faccio vedere questo
questo non è un beduino è un dottore che
ha un cammello che sulla testa un
antenna gps ha un pannello fotovoltaico
che produce energia che alimenta una
batteria che alimenta un frigorifero con
le medicine ecco qui in questa immagine
si nasconde un idea che non abbiamo
ancora capito che forse il futuro è
questa capacità di mettere insieme
innovazione tecnologica e conoscenza
antica come il mondo grazie
[Applauso]